[Applause]
[Music]
if i asked you to name the gambling
capital of the world and you said
las vegas you'd be very much mistaken
the world's center of gambling the
pounding heart the most important
enclave in the casino industry is not
nevada but about
6 000 kilometers away from the so-called
sin
city i'm referring of course to the
former portuguese colony
of macau you see as most of you probably
know macau is a small city located at
the mouth of the pearl river on the
south east coast of china just 60
kilometers that's less than 40 miles
from hong kong and
just like its close neighbor although
it's under chinese sovereignty it
maintains a large degree of autonomy
under the
one country two systems model
in this way macau has its own customs
its own currency and its own laws for
example while the chinese internet is
encumbered by the great firewall a huge
firewall that presents access to sites
like youtube
google or facebook among many others
macanese internet users like the hong
kongers
are free of all these restrictions but
what really makes this enclave stand
out are the fact that it is the most
densely populated territory in the world
more than 23 000 people per square
kilometer and
it has also become in just a few years
one of the richest places
on the planet
so let's take a look at the numbers my
friends with a surface area of barely 33
kilometer squares which is 20 times less
than that of berlin or 18 times smaller
than chicago and with a population of
just under 700
000 inhabitants this tiny place achieved
a gdp of over
50 billion dollars in 2019. that
is about 77 000 per capita this makes it
the richest autonomous territory
in all of asia and the fourth in the
world just behind monaco
liechtenstein and luxembourg
we are talking about a place so unusual
that thanks to all this enormous
economic growth it has seen its land
surface area grow by 65 percent
in just a few decades yeah that's right
and they haven't done it with old-school
conquests or anything like that in a
place like macau you'd better believe
every square meter counts and in order
to grow is reclaiming land
from the sea here you can see for
example the latest expansion is being
carried out in which it is planned that
over the next few years
more than 35 000 new homes will be built
as well as
hotels shopping centers and all kinds of
other facilities
but that is not macau's only unusual
feature is also
considered a fast learner you see like
hong kong the former portuguese colony
was returned to china at the end of the
20th century in macau's case
1999. as we mentioned previously the
transfer happened under the
one country two systems model
[Music]
however hold on one moment because
unlike hong kong the feeling of
belonging to china
is much stronger here according to
surveys while most hong kongers identify
strongly as hong kongers in macau most
citizens
feel chinese as well perhaps it has
something to do with the fact that in
macau's case more than half of the
residents were born
in mainland china but that's not all
while in hong kong the struggle and the
protest to maintain its status of
freedom have been
frequent ever since the transfer of the
territory to china in macau
things have been very very different in
2009 this territory adopted its own
national security law more lacks than
the one now approved in hong kong
but in a similar vein what's more during
all these years
demonstrations against china have been
repressed the use of surveillance and
facial recognition systems has increased
and
numerous legislators lawyers activists
and pro-democracy academics from hong
kong have even been censored and
restricted
let's just say that the idea in macau is
that civil liberties are relatively well
recognized as long as you don't dare
mess
with mother china if you do then don't
expect any sympathy that's why
beijing has always considered this place
to be the teacher's pet
in contrast to the rebel hong kong
but my friends having said all that
today on visualpolitik we are talking
about macau
for two reasons firstly because this
small territory has been the economy
that has been perhaps
the hardest hit by the coronavirus
pandemic in the entire
world to give you an idea it is
estimated that the gdp
fell by more than 50 in 2020. yeah
that's right a drop of 50 percent that
is a debacle a crash
a catastrophe a fact that visualpolitik
simply must comment on don't you think
and the second reason
has a lot to do with hong kong's
financial industry in particular
beijing's desire to make macau
a world-class international financial
center in a previous video we told you
all about how much the chinese economy
still depended
on hong kong so we have a few questions
what is happening
with macau's economy what explains the
wild reduction of more than 50
in gdp what are china's plans for this
small territory well my friends we are
going to answer
all these questions but first let's see
how macau has
changed under chinese sovereignty listen
up
[Music]
from portugal to china
on the 20th of december 1999 almost in
the new century macau separated from
portugal to become part of the people's
republic of china it had been under
portuguese administration for no less
than
442 years
[Music]
back in 1999 macau was a city of about
440 000 inhabitants had an area of just
over 23 kilometers squared and received
being the important commercial enclave
that it was around 7 million visitors
each year macau was a relatively rich
place compared to its neighbours with a
clear exception
of hong kong however
the best was yet to come on that day the
20th of december 1999 not only was there
a change in sovereignty but it also
signaled the start of a frenetic period
of change a change that would completely
transform the social fabric the economic
structure and even
the geography of this place within a few
years macau would not even be
recognizable to its own inhabitants in
just
20 years between 1999 and 2019 macau's
population grew
by more than 50 percent its surface area
by more than 40 percent the number of
visitors increased almost six-fold and
its gdp rose from some 6.5 billion
dollars to more than
50 billion dollars all of that in just
20 years
after that the fact that unemployment is
practically non-existent and the macau
government not only has no public debt
none but it has financial reserves of
more than 65 billion us dollars thanks
to the large surpluses that has been
accumulating
year after year
you see my friends the key to this
success lies in a more important player
in this transformation than marlon
brando was for the godfather the
gambling industry
since its liberalization in 2012 a huge
gigantic reign of billions of dollars in
public investment and revenue has fallen
on macau in a short time
huge tourist complexes with hotels and
casinos were built in fact three of the
five largest casinos in the world are
right here in this city just to give you
an idea the gambling industry in macau
had a turnover of 36 billion dollars in
four times more than in las vegas yeah
you heard me
four times more
however hold on just one moment because
as a chinese astronaut may say
beijing we have a problem
[Music]
things have gone smoothly during these
last 20 years but everything practically
everything has been linked to those
casinos yeah
it is true along with them and thanks to
the more than 40 million tourists who
have each spent time in the city each
year
hotels restaurants transportation
services etc
were opened but you see my friends
practically all the diversification
has been vertical that is to say it has
occurred with businesses that supply the
casinos or they provide services
to the players themselves but it has not
gone beyond that so the question the big
question that we can
and must ask ourselves is to what extent
is macau dependent
on gambling
[Music]
well my friend in 2019 the gambling
industry was responsible for more than
half
of macau's entire gdp and not only that
if we also add the businesses that are
largely dependent on gambling such as
hotels and restaurants then we can say
that directly or indirectly the gambling
industry is responsible for more than
60 percent of the economy of this
enclave and
that's not all the government itself
depends on the income from gambling
eighty-five percent of their income more
than eight out of ten potatoes macau's
currency that the government receives
comes from the gambling sector
[Music]
as you can see this is a dependence that
is simply and plainly
gigantic the problem is and let's just
think about this for just one moment
what unforeseen event has occurred
during 2020. i think you all know what
i'm talking about it is the triumphant
return of britney spears thanks to those
of us wearing yellow in the free britney
movement i'm kidding of course
it's the coronavirus and what has been
the result of the coronavirus pandemic
well
for example that international tourism
plummeted the hotels had to close for
long periods of time and then the
economic crisis has hit the pockets of
millions of people for a sustained
length of time you see my friends the
leisure and tourism industry has been
one of the hardest hits and with it
also that of the casinos check out what
has probably been the most dramatic
economic impact of the coronavirus
[Music]
worldwide
biggest economic recession in the world
i think it goes without saying 2020 has
been a very hard year for everyone and i
don't really think i have to convince
you on this point the health crisis
the millions of victims and the economic
crisis that followed 2020
will go down in history as a terrible
year but my friends if we're talking
about crisis
economic impact and recession macau
really takes the biscuit
if the city was already hit hard in 2015
when the xi jinping government began to
crack down on corruption in china
2020 has been its worst nightmare the
number of visitors has plummeted by
90 casino revenues have shrunk
dramatically and
with them government revenues as well
the result is that from a cow 2020 was a
complete economic debacle its gdp has
fallen by more than 50
50 this is by far the biggest recession
in the world
in one of the worst years in economic
history
the casinos lost and are still losing
hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars the hotels and
restaurants are empty the government had
to rescue the national airline air macau
and on top of that its main source of
foreign income the chinese economy has
slowed down
very significantly but that is not the
end of it in addition
some countries like cambodia have
announced new incentives to attract the
gambling industry as a way to overcome
their crisis
in their own countries you see my
friends if in macau they had little
doubt that gambling dependency was a
problem
they are now completely sure however the
dependency
is far from being curbed weight of
gaming sector and local economy has
continued to increase since 2016.
and it's here that keyword emerges the
buzzword the message pursued by all of
the city's politicians
diversification that is making macau's
economy
go much further than gambling why not
become a center for sports events
conventions
shows professional services medical
services new technologies
foreign students and so on develop a
real financial district and this
this is something that has a lot to do
with the tense situation in hong kong
listen up
the chinese nasdaq
[Music]
as we've covered in a previous video
macau and hong kong have very special
characteristics with respect
to chiang mai
for example unlike the asian giant these
two territories allow the free movement
of capital have currencies directly or
indirectly linked to the us dollar have
independence courts
and supervisors and even market
legislation comparable
to western countries
[Music]
that is precisely what has made hong
kong the third largest financial centre
on the planet
behind only new york and london this is
also the reason why the chinese economy
needs the services of hong kong's
financial industry in order
to raise dollars to safeguard money
capital to invest abroad
or to receive investments however well
what can i say those of you who follow
visualpolitik already know how things
are
in these parts
[Music]
during 2020 china has undertaken an
occupation of hong kong and relations
between the two territories are so tense
that they could provide material for a
thousand
soap operas and that that i would watch
and so in beijing
animosity towards the former british
colony is higher than ever and they are
no longer entirely comfortable with the
dependence that the chinese economy
continues to have
on hong kong that is precisely why many
have wanted to find an alternative and
do you remember who the pet student is
exactly it's macau
and in the former portuguese colony they
have a word that they can't get out of
their heads
diversification so one plus one
equals two the interests match so as we
often say around
here no sooner said than done
in 2016 the chinese government announced
that they would support the creation of
a financial centre
in macau and two years later in 2018 the
nam kwon group
an investment holding company of the
chinese government itself created the
chonghwa
macau financial asset exchange company
an exchange on which bonds of the
chinese government
the province of gulang zao are various
public companies of the agent giant have
already been issued
and are listed obviously it is still a
very small stock exchange
but it is already considered the third
largest bond market in all of asia
and that's not all now the next
objective is to launch a stock exchange
similar to the american nasdaq but
listed in one where technology companies
in the so-called greater bay area a
region including hong kong macau and
also the technology capital of china
shenzhen can attract financing and be
listed so the question is
will macau become a new international
financial center well the truth is that
these days
it kind of seems difficult
large financial centres need many
specialized professionals highly
developed regulations
experienced supervisors etc etc etc and
macau
has almost no land on which to build new
facilities and surprisingly
unlike hong kong it has not been
particularly open to attracting foreign
professionals
so you see at this point in time it
doesn't seem like an easy mission but
take note because right now the
interests of china
and macau coincide and if the asian
giant has shown us
one thing it is that it is very very
determined
the tax regime in macau is simple with
low taxes
a reason why many investors want to come
to macau some companies from mainland
china
want to establish their headquarters
here macau has to improve its office
facilities and services to retain
large companies and develop a central
business district
hul latseng chief executive of macau but
that is not the only project macau has
to grow and diversify its economy
another objective is to develop a two-in
industry that does not depend
on gambling but of course if you want to
attract tourists you have to give them a
reason to go
shopping centers theme parks leisure
centres cultural facilities new hotels
and so on and
if they want to attract companies then
it comes back to the same old problem
they need
space but in macau there is practically
no more buildable land so the question
is
how can they achieve this goal
well my friends have you run out of land
and need to expand
what can you do well why not rent some
well
you know what that's actually sort of
what they're doing macau has reached an
agreement with the chinese city of
zhuahai to jointly develop the island of
henguin an island of 106 square
kilometers that makes it three times
larger than macau the idea
is to turn henkwin into a kind of
special economic zone with its own rules
and which will house the spaces that are
most needed such as
theme parks universities technology
parks and sports stadiums as well as
providing
access to the chinese high-speed rail
and freeway networks
[Music]
for example the new campus of the
university of macau is already on this
island the investments that the macau
government intends to make in henchwind
are in the billions don't forget that
they have more than 60 billion in their
pockets and that right now achieving the
much desired diversification is their
number one priority
so get your wallets and ready set spent
in an ideal situation macau would be a
hub for banks
law firms and operations for some of the
world's top 500 companies
while heng jin could accommodate the
internal operations of these companies
and others
franco liu managing director of
seville's macau real estate
heng chin will be the orlando of china
macau is las vegas hong kong is new york
in one hour
you can have them all larry lung
executive of lai sun
so there you have it this is the
situation that is being experienced in
macau the only territory along with hong
kong that is administered by the one
country
two systems model a city that in just 20
years has managed to become one of the
most prosperous places
on earth but which has also suffered the
greatest economic impact from the
pandemic and is now struggling
to update itself the question is will it
succeed do you see yourself spending a
vacation in macau let us know what you
think in the comments as always we
really hope you enjoyed this video
please hit like if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
also don't forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not my dulcet tones finally
this channel is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage
and as always i'll see you next time if
you want to learn more about politics
and world affairs and hear some more of
my lovely voice
come check out the reconsider podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider at www.ricans
or on apple or google play or your
favorite podcatcher